bonjour Jean-Claude bonjour alors les
faits qu'on reprochait aux policiers ça
remonte à mars 2010 ils auraient
abandonné un homme sans abri sur une
voie de desserte à carclen les policiers
ils ont pas ni avoir conduit la victime
dans l'ouest de l'île mais pourtant il y
a pas eu de rapport il y a pas écrit de
notes à la après cet événement là ça ne
m'apparaît pas tellement normal ça
non c'est pas normal du tout et
d'ailleurs c'est une vieille pratique
policière de de se débarrasser d'un
détenu encombrants en allant le conduire
loin
du lieu où il a l'habitude de se tenir
et je vous rappelle par exemple que la
sortie du Québec avait cette mauvaise
manie vis-à-vis les autochtones du nord
de régler les problèmes d'ivresse en
allant et conduire les gens loin de leur
résidence et ça a été blanc mais c'était
vraiment ça c'est pratique là à Montréal
j'imagine que les policiers peuvent le
faire à l'occasion mais c'est pas aussi
en arabe que ça devrait bon il y avait
pas de rapport il y avait pas de notes
alors la juge était face à une preuve
incomplète si on peut dire mais c'était
pas exactement la parole de l'un contre
la parole de l'autre parce qu'il y avait
quand même toutes sortes de témoins là
qui chacun un petit bout de la preuve
mais il y avait rien là-dedans qui était
vraiment déterminant
non j'avais raison j'ai lu intégralement
le long jugement et effectivement quand
on a terminé la lecture on se dit elle
ne pouvait pas faire autrement la juge
Graton que dans l'arrivée à cette
conclusion-là parce que elle a respecté
tous les standards juridiques qui
s'appliquent en la matière
fardeau de la preuve de l'un par l'autre
la preuve de l'autre fiabilité
crédibilité des témoins elle a appliqué
des jugements de la Cour d'appel dans la
matière donc moi je suis convaincu que
ça serait extrêmement téméraire et
difficile pour le DPCP de vouloir faire
appel de cette jugement là parce qu'il y
a pas d'erreur factuelles énormes il y a
pas d'erreurs grossière en droit donc ce
serait vraiment un appel voie l'échec
effectivement et dans son jugement la
juge Graton elle remet quand même en
question plusieurs comportement des
policiers recondir un accusé loin comme
vous dites sans savoir chez qui on
allait le reconduire se poser le laisser
sur le bord de la route supposément
parce qu'il réclamait d'être laissé là
elle dit que leur défense laisse
perplexe mais ça est-ce que c'est de
nature à égratigner leur crédibilité
maintenant qui sont redevenues policier
en fait ils ont jamais cessé de l'être
mais maintenant qui retrouve leur poste
au tableau d'honneur d'un policier et si
jamais par exemple ces policiers-là sont
appelés comme témoin dans d'autres
dossiers c'est possible les avocats de
défense vont se passer le mot et vont
leur demander si ils ont déjà témoigné
avec franchise etc dans d'autres
dossiers et dépendant des réponses des
policiers on peut les contredire avec ce
qu'ils ont déjà dit ailleurs oui
effectivement bon on sait que le
plénière monsieur Levasseur il avait
fait une plainte en déontologie en mai
2010 à peu près donc un mois après les
événements mais on dirait que le pas
abouti cette plainte là qu'est-ce qu'on
doit en comprendre elle est juste pas
été retenue
de savoir pourquoi on n'a pas un
résultat du dossier de déontologie parce
que habituellement quand il y a une
plainte il faut que les responsables
disent le dossier est terminé il y a pas
de plan ou de répudiation des policiers
ou encore il y en a eu un puis la
sanction c'est ça la réprimante bon mais
là on a
aucunement d'informations sur le sujet
et ça serait peut-être le temps de
réveiller le dossier s'il existe encore
peut-être oui évidemment un des aspects
un peu complexe à l'histoire c'est que
ce Levasseur c'était un itinérant il y
avait pas vraiment d'adresse fixe il a
dû compter sur l'aide du YMCA pour
rédiger sa première plainte quand les
policiers enquêteurs au criminels le
cherchaient ils avaient du mal à le
trouver alors peut-être qu'il y a ça
aussi qui explique le fait qu'on soit
pas capable d'aller au bout d'un
processus
oui c'est pas simple et là si on revient
au dossier de déontologie c'est pas
toutes les poser une plainte il faut la
suivre il faut contribuer à son
avancement et si les responsables de
l'examen du dossier sont incapable de
joindre au moment propice le plaignant
un moment donné la sensation va être
forte de dire un dossier clos on le met
dans les archives dans la filière 13
comme on dit Jean-Claude Hébert merci
beaucoup de nous avoir parlé merci au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI